trying to invite his opponent into some  kind of  you know  interesting and non-standard structures  d4 d5 probably or d4 e5 i don't know  which one he would have chosen i think  magnus probably goes d5 here i think  it's more more to his style  but instead uh anton smirnoff played  very solidly with knight of three and  uh yeah inviting back to correct your  mistake yes yeah let's  let's go play spanish magnus but magnus  says no and  it ended it ends up being just more or  less a classical beards  uh with black choosing to play dc g6  move four  and uh  right now by move 10 uh it's a very very  quiet position i mean it's it just got a  little bit less quiet because uh anton  chose to castle queenside  but i still feel like uh it's it's going  to be  uh not that easy for magnus actually to  gen